wenn Kinder also Süßigkeiten essen es
ist aber wenig und einigermaßen gesund
das macht ja riesen Spaß daran erinnert
man sich ja auch also ich habe zum
Beispiel ich kam aus seiner Familie war
relativ arm und ich habe als Kinder sehr
gerne Mars Schokolade gegessen diese
Maßregel und wir hatten aber so wenig
Geld dass ich halt nicht den ganzen
Regel essen konnte dann wurde der Regel
geteilt ich muss den Riegel dann teilen
wodurch das schwarze Papier geteilt mit
meiner Schwester und dann habe ich immer
so geteilt dass man nicht besser ein
Stückchen mehr bekam sehr großzügig
sowas natürlich nicht da wirklich
mangunsten geteilt aber ja